Here we go we go
so this is almost final draft of the cover we've got our own boxes produced we've got our own cartridge mold produced those not too
upset saiga we've got our own logos on them big evil corporation cartridges thirsts
So the physical side of it is nearly ready to go want you to do now is finish the game
we caught up with you
how long ago was it i
finished the first level which is split into three acts and it's got most of the main mechanics running thank you a bachelor when the
kickstarter right it was mid kickstarter yehud kickstarter yeah yeah yeah and obviously
for those who haven't seen that video your kickstarter was successful which congratulations
Thank you very much wait with it then what's happening with the game um yeah it's taken just over a year so far to get
To this this point from the kickstarter we're about 90% finished there's a few audio things to fix up
Some bugs and it's going to head for closed beta testing
So i expect in the next couple of months we should have our gold build i understand things took off quite recently with
yeah
You got a bit of exposure when perhaps expect yeah i did an interview for the bbc i had a pr campaign
Planned to drop at the same time as the video
it went a bit earlier than i expected i was on my way to an event called play expo in blackpool and i got a
phone call saying that was on the tv so i have to quickly pull over on the motorway at the
starbucks and quickly launch our website it was a bit of a hairy move
have you had a lot more interesting start there
Yeah, it's been quite mani the past couple of weeks since that interview went life how other people contact me for magazine interviews and videos
and podcasts and things like that it's been non-stop
For the past couple of weeks let's be frank now did you quit your job for this yes i did quit my job for this
for better or worse
So what's what's going on long term then long term
Once we finished up releasing the megadrive version we're going to port it's the dreamcast
And then it's coming to modern consoles hopefully if the publishers are on board with it
After that we've got another two games up our sleeves so we can do this all over again
you're saying we and does um you work with people on this are they sort of like
characters you work with all the time or yeah for the first game i work with some contractors
it was mostly myself making the game though
For the next one i'm not sure i could stomach it again so i think i'm gonna hire some stuff
We see quite often people indie games producers
getting stuck in a rabbit hole of working on their own game for years and years and years how do you avoid that
Do you know you don't
but you
Know i suppose the question is it looks like you're getting near to completion so
it feels like there is light at the end of tunnel where as we hear of games getting stuck in
development hell for want of a better word
Is do you think this is something to do with the
limitations of the devices you're working on rather than
yeah
I think that play some part and there's only so much we can do on the rugged drive
and we can't upgrade the graphics engine we can't
add much more to it we're out of rom space we're using all four megabyte of the cartridge so
There's nothing more we can do to the game we've got, no space in ram rom we've got
no, cpu cycles left we've maxed the whole thing out
Which is a both a curse and a blessing because we have to say this is it now we've got
To polish this up and release it and feature creepers is not an issue here
when's the when you slated for release what's the latest kind of eta the plan is mid
2018 where we're penciling in late may early june at the moment
and it has its own set of registers
These aren't general-purpose registers for adding numbers and stuff each one has a specific purpose so one will be in control of the background-color
16 to d1 so we can see that d1 changes to 16 in hex and then add the two together